propriétaire de deux salles de concert
au centre-ville de toronto le portrait
sont les scènes musicales indépendants
du canada vont mal
comme partout au pays les fermetures
permanentes se multiplient à toronto
depuis que des revenus ont cessé au
printemps si la province autorise
désormais les concerts à l'intérieur
avec un maximum de 50 personnes et des
conditions sanitaires strictes
ce chiffre ne représente qu'une fraction
de la capacité de cette salle de
spectacle
même constat pour les propriétaires de
la légendaire tout avait il dit qu'il
n'est pas pressé de rouvrir mais que
sans l'aide du gouvernement il fera
faillite
j'en ai déjà font tous deux partie de la
coalition canadienne des salles
indépendantes qui milite pour la survie
de centaines de salles de spectacles à
travers le pays
sans le soutien du gouvernement fédéral
la coalition estime que 96% des
entreprises de musique indépendante
canadiennes risquent de mettre la clé
sous la porte d'ici la fin de l'année à
travers patrimoine canadien ottawa à
débourser 20 millions de dollars à
l'industrie du spectacle musical qui
emploie quelque 76 mille travailleurs
culturels au pays c'est sûr que ça va
aider certaines dalles a assuré pendant
le certains moments mais il faut
considérer que pour l'industrie du
spectacle
cette crise va durer au moins 24 mois
c'est la plupart des salles vont pas
ouvrir avant le milieu de 2012
on estime et même après que 15 où il va
avoir une période difficultés extrêmes
rendez vous il croit aussi qu'il y aura
une poussée importante de spectacles à
partir du printemps 2021 et que l'offre
écrasante créer un climat de concurrence
féroce pour l'industrie du concert un
pari difficile pour ce sous secteur de
l'industrie musicale qui était déjà
fragilisée même avant la pandémie
ici nicolas haddad radio canada toronto